soir claude blanchemaison merci d'être
avec nous alors comment donald trump at
il géré la crise du coronavirus selon
vous je crois que depuis trois mois on a
vu plusieurs donald trump ou pour en
tout cas jaffa celle de la longue traque
la première c'était le donald trump que
goguenard qui était dans le déni complet
de l'épidémie et qui disait c'est une
grosse grippe
et puis très rapidement on l'a vu venir
enfin rouen 10 ans mais de toute façon
la pandémie sera terminée à pâques
et puis les états unis ont inventé un
vaccin héros inventé un traitement pour
la maladie
et puis ensuite on a vu un peu plus
farfelues proposé que l'on injecte du
désinfectant voir de l'eau de javel aux
gens qu'ils étaient malades
et puis finalement de façon plus
sérieuse on l'a vu guerrier c'est à dire
on l'a vu affirmé que la pandémie venait
de chine
il a parlé de les russes chinois et il a
dit qu'il exigeait une enquête
indépendante pour démontrer que dans
quelles conditions ce virus était sortie
s'était échappée de ce laboratoire
chinois
et puis bien sûr là dessus s'est greffée
une affaires taïwanaises qui jettent un
voile n'est pas membre de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé que de l'intox veut
réformer complètement de fond en comble
cette organisation est peut-être
derrière se profile aussi la candidature
de taiwan naturellement qui est
inacceptable pour pékin puisqu'il ya une
seule chine
comme c'est la thèse en tout cas de pk
répit finalement peut-être le sujet plus
important pour donald trump
c'est l'économie alors il a fait voter
par le congrès le 23 avril un plan de
relance qui est un plan de relance 500
milliards de dollars
et puis avec son vice-président en
peines et bien et discute régulièrement
avec les gouverneurs pour réguler la
dose de déconfinement qui permet un peu
le retour à l'ouverture de l'est
me et puis le respect des obligations
sanitaires alors toute blanche maison
selon vous quelle influence peut avoir
cette crise du coronavirus sur les
élections de novembre parce qu'on n'en
parle pas beaucoup en tout cas pas
depuis la france 1 bah oui c'est
évidemment un peu tôt pour dire puisque
les élections se rendre dans six mois
mais enfin six mois c'est en effet après
demain et dans la halle trump de penser
évidemment cac à cette échéance alors on
peut constater qu'il qu'il dans les
sondages il a conservé la base de ces de
ses partisans puisque il ya quelques
jours il avait encore 47 % de l'opinion
favorable et que cette base c'est
essentiellement le reste belle aux états
unis est élevé des milieux évangélistes
une occupe l'ensemble de l'espace
médiatique avec son conseiller son
sympathique conseiller médical qu'il
contredit qui le contredit souvent le dr
fauci qui devient quelqu'un de très
populaire aux états unis mais qui a
conseillé de ne pas aller trop vite dans
le déconfinement en revanche son
opposant vraisemblable qui sera désigné
par là naturellement le parti démocrate
est bien ne peut plus tenir de congrès
est fait de temps en temps des
l'interventions confiné depuis chez lui
par conséquent effectivement dans cette
bataille médiatique
l'avantagé pour le moment à trump mais
naturellement ça va dépendre de ce qui
va se passer en matière de développement
de la pandémie
à la fin du mois on sera probablement
aux alentours de 100 mille morts aux
etats unis c'est quand même beaucoup
et puis l'économie américaine ne va pas
bien donc effectivement les gouvernants
heures 20 des confiner le plus vite
possible pour relancer l'activité
merci beaucoup claude blanchemaison
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france rappelle que vous êtes expert en
relations internationales ancien
ambassadeur